nephews.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah subhanahu waala mentions to us as
we have been listening to in the past
few days.
He mentions to us the incident when
chose disbelief over belief.
chose
to turn away from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala over accepting and embracing the
Quran the prophet sallallahu alaii
wasallam and the worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala alone without any
partners
the question here a lot of times many of
us
we have a kind of lingering emotion
that is
often incorrect.
It's a misconception.
It's a misconception that many people
have
and that is the idea
that those who disbelieved
in the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam especially
during his lifetime
that they disbelieve
with a sincere intention.
Meaning they disbelieve sincerely.
Disbelieve sincerely. What does that
mean?
Meaning that
they hear the Quran, they hear the
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They meet the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam and they genuinely
in their heart of hearts believe
that he is not a prophet and the Quran
is not from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
their heart of hearts
and this is incorrect.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
We would not punish any people before
first sending to them a messenger.
Meaning before they have the ability to
make a conscious decision
that they know the truth but instead
insist upon disbelief.
this occurrence happened here. And what
do people if if it's not truly confusion
or sincerity that drives people to
disbelieve, what is it then? What is the
leading cause? If we were to really boil
it down, what is the reason that the
people of Quraysh other people d
throughout the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's lifetime, those who have met
him, those who disbelieved, those who
fought against him, if we were to really
boil it down,
what was the reason that they
disbelieved?
In so many words,
they did not reject necessarily
the Quran but rejected its implications.
They did not necessarily reject the
Sunnah or Muhammad Sall. Wasam, but they
rejected the implications. And even
today, if you have met people that have
been perhaps on the fence about becoming
Muslim and you they know about Islam,
but they reject it or or refuse to
become Muslim. If you were to really ask
them and get to the bottom of it, you'll
find that it's not really the Quran,
it's not really Islam that they're
rejecting per se. They're rejecting the
implications that this religion will
have on their lives because a shan
hyperfocuses
on implications when he scares people
away from believing in Islam. What do we
mean by implications? Meaning if I
become Muslim
for instance with what were the
implications? He knew in his heart of
hearts that Musa was a messenger. Allah
tells us that he knew that
that they outwardly rejected it. But
Pharaoh outwardly rejected it. But in
his heart of hearts, he knew that it was
the truth. Why did this happen? Again,
because of the implications.
What were the implications?
, he's not going to be Pharaoh
anymore. He's not going to be the
pharaoh. He's not going to be rich. He
can't do what he wants to do. He's not
going to be able to or he won't have.
This is why people turn away.
You look at Abu Jah. What was the reason
he turned away? Were the implications?
The implications were if I accept Islam,
I have to become a follower to Beni
Hashim tribalism.
And no way will I ever be become a
follower to Beni Hashim me and my tribe.
You look at Abdullahb
the leader and spearhead of the
hypocrites in Medina.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us about
throughout the chapters that were
revealed in Medina in the Medini era. He
is
similar in many ways in his enmity
and his antagonism of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and his enmity
towards Islam. He is very similar to Abu
Jah.
He he could he could even be looked at
as a kind of Abu Jah of
Medina. What was the reason that he
rejected?
Because the companions tell us Zabit and
others they tell us why did he reject?
Because he was the chieftain and the
leader of the Khaz tribe in Medina.
and he was considered the be all and end
all chieftain of Medina. Anything that
happened people when they wanted to
get married, they'd go to Abdullahb Sal.
He was wealthy. people had disputes.
They'd come to him to settle their
disputes. Any gathering he sat in, he
was, you know, highly respected and and
honored. And so what happened here? This
caused him to reject Islam.
How did it cause him to reject Islam?
He was supposed to be the king of
Medina.
He was supposed to be the king of Medina
to the point that some companions said
just before the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam arrived at Medina,
he was almost going to be crowned as the
king of Medina, the king of
[Arabic recitation]
came and in his mind ruined all of that.
It wasn't because he didn't believe the
Quran was the words of Allah. A person
who is genuinely confused
and has sincerity and is seeking with
their all and every fiber of their being
to be guided but is genuinely
misunderstanding.
This person is not eligible for hell.
Hellfire is a place you have to choose
to go to. It's a place that you have to
make a conscious decision to go to.
Paradise, no. There are people that
enter paradise that never made that
decision merely from the grace and mercy
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. But the
hellfire, no. You have to use your own
free will and have the knowledge of what
you're rejecting and consciously choose
to reject and oftent times choose over
and over and over and over again to
reject until Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
finally
punishes a person with damnation as we
see in the story of as we see in the
story of the people of L the people of
Hoot the people of
the people of Muhammad sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam the chieftains of
Quraysh these people were not punished
immediately for 13 long years they made
the decision over and over and over
again to reject why were the the
implications
and those implications you'll hear them
in people's speech even to this day as
we mentioned if you meet someone who's
knows about Islam and maybe even says
good things about Islam You say, "Well,
why don't you become Muslim?"
Well, you know, my family wouldn't like
that. It's the implications. Why don't
you become Muslim? Well, you know, this
this would be something that is that is
upsetting to my wife. I don't want to
upset my wife. My wife won't let me
become Muslim. Right? I've actually had
people tell me that before. Or, "Why
wouldn't you become Muslim? the the the
diet, the Muslim diet is too much. They
they really need their pork and bacon.
Bacon is very important to their lives,
right? Or they're they love to gamble
and drink and and they love these things
and they just can't leave it off, right?
Or they're a big musician and they're a
superstar and how am I going to turn
that? What are my fans going to think?
This is this is the reason people reject
Islam. It's not cuz they're genuinely
seeking the truth. and Islam is somehow
unclear. From the first page of the
Quran,
it is incredibly clear. Even its
translation is unlike anything you have
ever heard or read anywhere else.
And so Allah tells us of this choice
and the implications
in these verses of Mud.
Before we move on to the descriptions of
hell in this chapter, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us of
what is what is going on tonight.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of
the
rejection of those implications.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
regarding
When he heard the Quran and he
understood that this is from Allah and
in his heart of hearts believed it, he
started to think. Allah tells us he
started to think and then weigh
the implications of believing in this
Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then even
gives us the the expressions on his face
that tell us the exact moment
when he rejected Islam.
He says
Another
soften
another.
Now the implications came into his mind.
Allah said
he looked off into the distance
thinking remembering those words he
heard of the Quran and how incredible
they were.
He says, "And then
he scrunched his brow and frowned." What
is the scrunch of the brow and frowning?
That facial expression.
What is that?
This is the facial expression of someone
who is taken over by his ego and
arrogance.
What came into his mind when he thought
that?
How could I How could I be a follower to
this man? I'm the one who should have
been a prophet. He said that in, as
we've mentioned before, I'm the richest
man here. If anyone should have been a
prophet, it should have been me. And
second of all, if I follow this man, I'm
going to lose my followers. Who am I
going to be? He's going to take my
place. He didn't work for this. He
didn't earn what I earned. I pulled
myself up from my bootstraps. I taught
myself and learned and it's my children
and mine and mine and mine and mine and
mine and who is he to come now and ruin
that.
And then he turned away
and
embraced his arrogance. That was the
moment. If you were to somehow go and
ask, if you were to fish
out of the bowels of hell where he is to
current is to reside. If you were to
fish him out of there and say, "Mention
to me the moment you ended up here, it
would be this moment."
That would be that moment.
The same moment Allah mentions about
Pharaoh in surah
in
distract
take questions after inshallah.
Thank you.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in surah and other verses of the Quran,
he gives us a very similar
a very similar
setup with Pharaoh as he did with
very similar.
This is the moment he chose to go to the
hellfire.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Well, now that you've made that
decision and committed to the idea that
I have to reject this, not because it's
not the truth, but I have to reject this
because it is because of the
implications."
Now I have to answer. I mean, I can't
just reject it. I have to explain where
this Quran came from then. If he's not a
prophet, where did it come from? He has
to save face. I can't go out into public
and tell people I don't re I reject
Islam because I'm too arrogant to follow
it. Not even could muster up such
audacity. We have to come up with
something, some facade to cloak this
arrogance. So he says this is a type of
magic that he is inheriting and taking
from others. He's being taught it. He's
bringing it to us. We haven't met these
people or this jin or they're bringing
him this magic. They're teaching it to
him and we don't know. We haven't met
these people or
these are the words of of of human
beings. These are not the words of
Allah. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
says and rebukes. He says
for
[Silence]
abwab.
forchech.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says I will
indeed
I shall soon commit him to suffer. This
word saka
it is a name a proper name of the names
of jahannam.
It is also one of the names of one of
the seven gates of hell. Hellfire has
seven gates. One of the names of these
seven gates is
as mentioned by
in his
he says
And and how can you come to know and
visualize
what is? He's speaking to the prophet
sallall.aii
meaning how it it is so immense.
No amount of words could truly
allow you to visualize vividly just how
horrific
is. He says
it will be brought out on the day of
judgment clear and in front of everyone.
And Muslim
said,
[Silence]
he said that the hellfire will be
dragged out of its place of concealment
on the day of judgment,
dragged out for people to see.
Attached to it are 70,000
ropes.
On each of these 70,000 ropes are 70,000
angels pulling its weight and its dread
behind them.
He says
in its description,
this place
enough for you to know about it is that
whoever is in it, it neither leaves them
to die nor does it allow them to live.
What a terrible existence. They merely
exist. They're not allowed to live and
they don't die.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
numerous places in the Quran, they will
not be given the sweet, sweet death that
they pray for at every moment.
Nor will they be allowed to live a
single moment in any kind of peace to
where you could say this is alive. They
merely exist in anguish and agony and
terror that will continue to intensify
the for the rest of eternity. He says
and on it are 19 angels which are
commissioned with overseeing the the
tortures of the hellfire. Now these are
19 angels. Under them are many many
angels that are commissioned but these
are 19 that are the caretakers and the
gatekeepers of the hellfire.
We will get into their descriptions
inshallah in our next gathering in
the next few verses of this
incredible surah.
All subal.
Allah subhanahu
[Silence]
alhamdulillah